and what you need to know this morning
begins in San Francisco and Denver where
the second deal of the day was done it
was Mohamed Sanu from Atlanta to New
England while we were on the air
yesterday and later in the day Emmanuel
Sanders initially remember the
Pittsburgh Steelers who when he was a
restricted free agent signed an offer
sheet with the Patriots that was matched
by the Steelers a year after that he
joined the Broncos via free agency he's
been there ever since and now he is a
member of the San Francisco 49ers as a
49ers tried to bolster one of the areas
of weakness on that team one of the only
areas of weakness on that team really
for the Patriots the best team in the
AFC yeah for the 49ers the best team in
the NFC these were the areas where they
needed help and they've gone out and
gotten them Chris and you know that's
what great teams do they identify where
they need help and they go find a way to
get it yeah and there are very important
positions to both of these football
teams and Emmanuel Sanders and Mohamed
Sanu
will fill similar roles in a lot of ways
for both teams but more specifically to
the 49ers and Emanuel Sanders I mean you
said it there's just not a guy right
there right now where they can depend on
they got a lot of good they got a lot of
guys that oh he's good in this role as
far as route running Marquis Goodwin
oh he's a great like take the top off
the defense let's throw the ball down
the field type of guy George kiddo works
the middle of the field and Shanahan
comes up with a bunch of gadget plays
for him or creative place I should say
Deebo Samuel is a little bit of a hybrid
you know reverse running back can do
some things in the pass game but I think
ultimately what really and just you know
knowing Kyle Shanahan's offense and I
watch it every week they don't have that
guy Mike who on 3rd and 6 ok they need
they need a 6 or 7 yard completion where
the wide receiver can read the coverage
and run the proper route and be on the
same page mentally as a guy like Jimmy
Garoppolo there's that guy doesn't exist
for the 49ers right now Donte Pettis was
the guy I think they were hoping could
do that but this is where Emanuel
Sanders will be really valuable to the
Shanahan offense and for Jimmy Garoppolo
okay so the 49ers get both emanuel
saying
and a 20 25th the Broncos get a third
round and a fourth round pick from the
49ers it's got that weird back in let's
try to balance it I always hate that I
feel like the GM's are trying to be cute
when they do that just trade him for a
third-round pick and be done with it
well right you'll give us a four and
we'll give you a five and really how
different are the picks gonna be the
Broncos pick in round five is going to
be near the top and the 49ers pick in
round four is gonna be near the bottom I
mean how many spots are we really
talking about here but I feel like that
is someone in the front office of each
team trying to justify their existence
when they're dropping the pebbles on the
scale to get it to balance out just
right because it can't be fair if it's
just a manual Sanders for a third-round
pick Chris here's what came out
yesterday though when John Elway who
said 11 days ago that none of these guys
are gonna be traded the Broncos are all
in on trying to make the best out of
what they currently have right Elway on
a conference call explained why he
changed his mind here's that way from
yesterday you know I think eventually
with you know with what happened after
the Tennessee game and where we were and
the opportunity to with the berry that
were getting for him decided it was the
best thing for our football team to
trade immanuel done when he said what
happened with the Tennessee game are you
able to explain that no I'm not into
that he had one catch for no yards
against Tennessee but the Broncos won 16
to nothing now look it sounds like he
was probably upset he didn't get the
ball more and I think it's bad for him
for a receiver to be upset about not
getting the ball on a day when the
Broncos won their first home game of the
season and they shut out the Tennessee
Titans so maybe that was a straw that
broke the camel's back and got them to
think about moving Emmanuel Sanders I
also think a major factor is getting
your butts kicked four days later by the
Kansas City Chiefs on your home field
and you realize we're not very good and
it's time to turn some of these current
veteran players into future assets
exactly right and Emmanuel Sanders the
age and parties added in his career this
is the right time to make that type of
move if you are the Denver Broncos and
you find
okay we're not going to the playoffs
this year which it to your point I think
that's what they realized last Thursday
like come on the chances of them you
know winning nine more games from here
on out or going on a run where they only
lose one more game or whatever it may be
I mean that that's not happening so they
read the situation Emmanuel Sanders
obviously was not happy and you had a
suitor with Kyle Shanahan and John Lynch
and the 49ers who certainly want him and
I've been surprised with Emmanuel
Sanders first off just how healthy he's
been I mean this guy that came off an
Achilles tear last year and he's looked
pretty damn good I mean he is a very
good route runner can still scare people
down the field maybe not the way he
could 2-3 years ago but he's very
effective and I think he will slowly
indoctrinate himself into this San
Francisco offense and be really the
go-to guy I think in a lot of big
situations other than George Kittel
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports